un prof d'histoire obsédé par napoléon
une prof d'anglais un brin acariâtre et
le cancre boulard depuis 2000 ils n'ont
pas pris une ride
des personnages devenus cultes au fil
des années et qui ont même fait l'objet
de deux films en 2013 et 2014
un succès difficile à expliquer pour son
créateur au début c'était c'était
justement le thème qui posait problème
c'est à dire que nous quand on a vu des
éditeurs on nous a dit les enfants même
si je n'ai pas que des lecteurs qui sont
des enfants monique quand les enfants de
l'école n'ont pas envie de retomber
dedans donc ça marchera jamais je pense
moi plutôt que ça a marché parce que
justement les gamins s'y retrouver je
suis content de voir des gens de 25 ans
qui effectivement me disent que je
continue voilà j'ai acheté le dernier
alors oui je pense qu'il voit plus il
voit pas la même chose que ce qu'ils
voyaient de 11 12 ans mais ce qui compte
c'est qu'ils soient fidèles quoi ça fait
plaisir
échanger avec les lecteurs un jeu auquel
et rock se prête volontiers
il a même aidé à élaborer le nouvel
agenda de l'agglomération versailles
grand parc avec des enfants depuis
plusieurs années il participe au
festival de la bd de but qu il sera
présent pour la 24e édition des 7 et 8
octobre prochains
j'y vais chaque année depuis déjà un
certain temps c'est assez sympa parce
que déjà je retrouve j'aime bien les
gens qui qu'il met en forme qui s'en
occupe il n'y a pas tellement d'autres
occasions devant le public que dans les
festivals de bd donc
celui ci comme les autres évidemment
plus être public pouvons avoir un public
un petit peu varié et ça c'est
intéressant pour nous l'occasion de
faire découvrir le dix neuvième tome de
la série sorti le mois dernier
même après 17 ans les profs ne sont pas
encore prêts à quitter leur lycée